versprechen darf man nicht brechen das
weiß doch jedes kind eigentlich seit
nunmehr einem jahr stellte kohona
pandemie unser leben auf den kopf
seitdem hören wir viele reden viele die
mut machen viele die die hoffnung wieder
zerstören
hoffnung machen das können sie die
politiker aber welche versprechen haben
und tatsächlich enttäuscht bild schaut
zurück und stellt sie auf die top 3 der
worte die schnell an bedeutung verloren
haben buhrufe und enttäuschte gesichter
menschen machen ihrer wut luft so
geschehen ende august letzten jahres
gesundheitsminister jens spahn spricht
auf einem marktplatz in bottrop und
verspricht
nur drei monate später kommt es ganz
anders
seit mitte dezember befinden wir uns
wieder in einem blog down die läden
dicht deutschland im ausnahmezustand
ein ganzes land steht still noch immer
kurz nach weihnachten dann wieder ein
hoffnungsschimmer dass großangelegte
impfen beginnt auch hierzulande etliche
impfzentren millionen menschen warten
und warten bis heute obwohl es vor genau
einem monat noch hieß denn wir haben
genug mehr als genug impfstoff bestellt
und zwar nicht nur von einem sondern
gleich von mehreren herstellern auch
dass ein strategischer ansatz den wir
sehr bewusst gewählt haben nicht auf ein
pferd nur zu setzen sondern auf mehrere
bestellt wurde angeblich viel geliefert
nur wenig bis gestern wurden laut lka
gut 1,7 millionen impfungen verabreicht
nur gut 230.000 davon sind zwei kämpfte
zur verdeutlichung das sind 1,9 prozent
der deutschen bevölkerung versprochen
gebrochen mit diesen worten gibt die
kanzlerin vorerst einer woche den
ausblick auf das was sein könnte wenn
alles so ist wie uns die
unternehmen jetzt zugesagt haben dann
werden wir nach dem zweiten quartal
schon deutlich viel mehr menschen
geimpft haben und wir werden so ist
unser ziel und wenn die zulassung auch
so eintreten kann man das schaffen dann
werden wir auch bis ende des sommers
habe ich gesagt und wiederhole ich hier
gerne auch jedem bürger ein ins angebot
gemacht haben mittlerweile ist auch
diese prognose kaum mehr einzuhalten
versprochen gebrochen
mehr nachrichten und breaking news nur
bei bate schau dich hier das nächste
video an und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren